Trump is not manly Trump is not manly
reason number one he is not a provider
I mean remember those tax cuts
they didn't help you or me
but they helped his rich buddies
while we were all struggling
he was handing out cash to his billionaire friends like it was candy
Trump is also not a protector
he doesn't protect women he literally endangered us with his abortion bans
and when it came to protecting us during a pandemic
we just learnt that he literally gave covid test to Putin
instead of protecting us he's also weak
strong men do not need to compensate and put down other people
to feel good about themselves
strong men do not put down women or disabled people
or Haitian immigrants in order to convince you to like them
Donald Trump's levels of insecurity are astronomical
so no Donald Trump is not masculine
in fact he embodies the weakest version of it
I mean I went to the streets
and asked men to name one manly thing that Donald Trump has done
and I got a lot of long silences and crickets
even from men who were saying that they were gonna vote for him
Kama Harris has bigger balls than Donald Trump